hello very good morning to you just
weeks after taking office this morning
the new Chancellor will unveil a major
plan to boost economic growth quasi
quateng is expected to announce tens of
billions of pounds of tax cuts and
increased spending which he says will
break the Vicious Cycle of stagnation in
his mini budget
the plans are expected to require a
sharp rise in public borrowing here's
our Deputy political editor suncodes
they hope it's a plan to make the
British economy Bloom growth the new
focus of a new government with massive
tax cuts the order of the day welcome
news says this small business things
have gone up so much in our trade the
same was with the food with fuel
everything personally for me tax cuts
would be massive that would be one of
the main things obviously to give us
some tax breaks maybe to help us a bit
more to get over covid with with
everybody was closed and things were
quiet
new chancellor quasiquarting has been
the local MP here in stains part of
spellthorne in Surrey for more than a
decade now the whole country about to
hear what he'll do differently to rev up
the economy slashing rules he thinks
hold back growth junking the rise in
National Insurance and corporation tax a
boost for tourism and almost 40 low tax
investment zones
these are more modest outlay hand-picked
by the chancellor and being packed off
to conservative conference
but the brewery owner who made them
needs more support
this industry really is struggling and
hasn't recovered from covid
we really need measures that will help
us get back on our feet especially as
we've seen 400 plus rises in the energy
estimates and costs already so we were
already struggling before but with these
increases it becomes unsustainable
whether it's reversing tax Rises cutting
stamp Duty or making it easier and
cheaper to build in certain parts of the
country
quasi-quarting's first major statement
to Parliament as Chancellor with more
than 30 measures costing more than two
billion pounds every minute is based on
a big bet he's hoping that as he spends
and spends and spends that growth will
come and voters will be grateful
a mini budget but a big gamble there'll
only be one chance to spend on this
scale this side of an election will the
bill be too big for comfort
Sam coat Sky News
I'm joined now by the leveling up
secretary Simon Clark very good morning
to you Simon Clark so we're told that
the central mission of this so-called
fiscal event is to ignite growth by
lowering taxes and cutting regulation
but where is the evidence that cutting
taxes will stimulate growth at The
Institute for fiscal studies say it's a
gamble at bear so is this plan just a
big gamble no it's not it's it's about
asserting that we if we want to get back
to the the trend growth that this
country enjoyed before the 2008
financial crisis the two and a half
percent average that we used to see then
we need to get back to the the measures
that we know work and which of course we
saw during the 1980s and 1990s helped to
stimulate a period of huge prosperity in
in the British economy and that is to
say making sure that alongside clearly a
major program of government government
investment that we focus on the real
drivers of growth and that is to say
reducing the burden of tax facing both
businesses and families that's something
which the Prime Minister put at the
heart of her leadership campaign this
summer and today we're going to see that
translated into actions through what I
think will be a really important uh and
and game-changing financial statement
okay well let's take a look at one
element of it we're expecting a
scrapping of the planned Rising
corporation tax you talked about how
business will be affected but what
difference will that make for example to
growth will it actually work the
institute for Public Policy research has
questioned this theory that low
corporate taxes boost growth they point
out that in 2019 the UK had the lowest
corporation tax in the G7 and yet we
also had the lowest rate of business
investment well corporation tax is just
one of the levers that we that we need
to uh to look at as part of the uh the
drive to unlock growth and clearly it's
not for me to preempt what the chance of
is going to say in a statement uh later
this morning you cited National
Insurance a few moments ago it's
obviously vital that we honor the pledge
that was made during the 2019 general
election campaign that we wouldn't raise
at that tax and that's something which
the chancellor has confirmed will now be
scrapped with effect from the 6th of
November that increase in in in tax
that's worth 330 pounds for 28 million
people but he's obviously going to go
much further than that and he's going to
tackle uh what is a record high tax
burden on on families and and businesses
reflecting clearly the fact we've gone
through some extraordinarily difficult
years but setting up a fundamentally new
approach to go for growth to make sure
that we we win the argument that a more
successful enterprise economy is good
for the whole of this country and it's
that which we need to unlock today
well if you're confident that this plan
will work and growth will be boosted why
has the office for Budget responsibility
not been asked to produce its
independent analysis of what it means
for the economy is would normally go
alongside statements like this well the
obr will be producing a a full forecast
later in the financial year now well
precisely because as they themselves are
said that given this is a short notice
event they would not be able to complete
the usual quality of analysis that they
would offer and so they will be can ask
to conduct that modeling alongside uh
subsequent events later in this
financial year this is uh an attempt to
kick-start growth it's delivered at
short notice it's a great speed and
we've been working on it a huge rapidity
over recent days but it is not something
which the obr can model uh to their
usual to their usual standards but they
will be they will be doing so in due
course but but are you concerned of the
effect that could have on the market is
the pound for example has taken a hit
recently don't the markets need to see
what these policies will do for the
economy and whether we can afford them
what the markets want to know is whether
the UK economy is going to grow and that
is something which the chancellor is
setting are the absolute heart of our
strategy that the UK wants to uh to get
back to those levels of trend growth
that we used to enjoy and critically
catch up with other parts of the world
where Dynamic economies are surging
ahead the risk is that Europe is in a a
pattern of stagnation Britain can't
afford to be part of that and we need to
to set out today how we are going to uh
get to get to a much higher level of
sustainable growth and that's that's
going to be driven through lowering the
burden of tax well if corporation tax if
the rise in corporation tax is scrap
then businesses will be very happy Liz
truss has acknowledged that the
scrapping of the rise in National
Insurance will benefit the wealthier
more labor says that this government has
moved from leveling up to to trickle
down you're leveling up secretary are
you worried about this government being
seen to be helping or helping the better
off more than the poorer people uh
absolutely not this is I mean this whole
term trickle down is such a nonsense and
is itself a uh a center-left
mischaracterization of what this
government is all about we need to grow
the economy because a more successful
economy is good for everybody if we have
a more successful economy then the tax
state goes up that tax is what funds our
Vital Public Services it is a virtuous
circle as the chancellor will be saying
later today we need to get to a
situation where the UK economy is
stronger is more Dynamic is more robust
that in turn makes it easier to pay for
the services on which the poorest and
the most vulnerable in our society rely
and is leveling up secretary I'm
absolutely delighted that we're going to
be going for growth going for new
policies like investment zones which
will benefit some of the the most Left
Behind communities in our country and
help to unlock uh growth opportunities
there so I'm really excited about today
and I'm absolutely confident that a more
successful economy driven by lower
taxation is the way to Greater
prosperity for everybody regardless of
where you come from or what your
circumstances are that's so interesting
because when you achieve secretary to
the treasury not so long ago when the
National Insurance rise was announced
you were a big fan of it so why are you
so pleased that that's now being
reversed well I served the government of
the day and with the new prime minister
it comes new uh prerogatives but to be
clear we're going to stand behind the
investment in our NHS and social care
that was announced by Boris Johnson as
prime minister we're just going to pay
for it through General taxation rather
than through a specific Levy so there's
going to be no uh change to our level of
commitment to fund the Health Service
what we are saying is that we want to
have a more Dynamic enterprise economy
alongside it which will obviously make
it easier to pay for that Health Care
over the long term
well let's look a little bit more about
how it's being paid for because back
when the National Insurance rise was
being introduced you said then that the
government had to be honest with people
about the need to raise the money you
said it was simply irresponsible for us
to whack it all on our debt when we know
that's already at a record high and you
said that just amounts to taxes being
deferred for the Next Generation so are
you now being irresponsible whacking
this all in our debt no because what
you're doing now is you're going for
growth alongside it I think the critical
thing is we need to get the economy
growing so that frankly the economic
growth trajectory outstrips that of our
debt and that is what the uh what the
government is determined to help deliver
the fundamental difference between our
philosophy and labor is that they would
be they would be spending on
non-productive outputs we will be making
a statement today which is about
actually unlocking the productive
sectors of the economy if you get if you
if you are creating the conditions for
stronger underlying growth through tax
cuts that's a very different proposition
to just spending uh for spending sake
which is what the opposition I'm afraid
uh remain committed to doing we are
trying to unlock better Trend growth and
that puts obviously the whole question
of how you pay for public services on a
fundamentally different footing you're
talking about a very different economic
proposition and a very frankly bold and
welcome switch to an open Embrace of
growth that's the main the main task of
the ex jacket
we're told that part of the plans are
these local investment zones in 38 areas
in England which involve amongst other
things liberalizing local planning to to
release more loud for housing and
Commercial development so how much say
will local residents have in the
planning and the building of this
infrastructure in their area my
investment zones are a really important
part of the chancellor is uh statement
and I should I shouldn't preempt that
but what I what I can say is that these
zones will only happen where there is uh
local consent and we've been very clear
about that in the discussions we've been
having uh with local authorities and
Mayors over recent days as we've been uh
testing the proposition with them
there's I'm delighted to say there's
been a huge level of enthusiasm in those
discussions and uh we hope to be able to
make very rapid progress over the next
few weeks in terms of confirming where
these zones will be located but to be
clear they will only happen where there
is a local appetite for them to occur
there will be no top down in position of
these zones we want to obviously create
the best possible opportunity uh for for
local areas to to get both targeted tax
breaks and a liberalized planning regime
and that's something which we'll be
setting up more detail on uh over the
coming hours
well on the subject of local appetite
for things Jacob Bruce mogg announced
yesterday the government's lifting the
ban on fracking would you welcome
fracking in your constituency well the
key point with with fracking uh as with
investment zones is that it will happen
where there is local consent and where
there is local consent only it is right
clearly that we look to explore all
possible sources of energy generation uh
including Renewables uh the nuclear
industry and conventional oil and gas to
make sure that we never again find
ourselves in a position where we are so
vulnerable to the actions of our hostile
state in this case right so you want it
in your constituency well no to be clear
Anna this is a matter for local
communities and for local authorities
and the planning process to determine
wherever uh this can this can take place
that is that the consent log on where
the fracking goes ahead in any community
so it's not a matter for me or for any
uh MP it's the question of what local
community communities want
and today's a fiscal event you described
it as radical I think if it is such a
radical change to how things were done
before should there not be a general
election and this be put to the people
no the the country at this point needs
uh Clarity and certainty of government
that we had a general election uh less
than three years ago there's a a
government with a strong majority in the
House of Commons and there's an urgent
need for Action today that's why we've
brought forward this package at the
speed that we have precisely because as
the world uh goes through this extremely
challenging winter uh driven obviously
by the ongoing after effects of covert
but most seriously by Russia's criminal
actions in Ukraine or attempts to
weaponize energy this country needs
growth now that's what we're going to
deliver and it's going to make life
better for everybody okay well Simon
Clark Secretary of State for leveling up
thanks very much indeed for your time
thank you appreciate it
let's take you straight to Downing
Street and talk to our political
correspondent Rob Powell so Rob at this
big event takes place just in a matter
of a few hours now so what have we
learned about what will it will involve
well I think we're starting to get an
idea Anna of the scale of what they are
planning today and the break from the
past because I think whilst the
presentation and the choreography of all
this will look a bit like a mini version
of a budget I think the content of what
we'll hear today and also the tone will
be anything but miniature and I think we
got started to get that a little bit
from Simon Clark just then he set out
right at the top of that interview that
they wanted to get growth economic
growth back to where it was
pre-financial Crisis pre-2008 and said
that they needed to go back to measures
that they knew were so suggesting
essentially that the approach to the
economy for the last 14 years hasn't
been working now a reminder that 12 of
those 14 years has been under
conservative-led government and that
gives you an indication I think of the
extent to which they will be setting out
a break from previous conservative
policies towards the economy today and
then in terms of policy and in terms of
content we already know a lot of what is
going to come around that reversal of
the National Insurance rise changes to
corporation tax probably a cut to stamp
Duty as well there are still big big
questions though about how all this is
paid for in the long term we know in the
short term that this will come from more
borrowing there is uncertainty about
what that will mean for how the UK has
viewed internationally and whether it is
essentially viewed as as much of a safe
bet in terms of handling the economy as
it always has been and Simon Clark said
in that interview that the long-term
plan is basically to pay for it from the
tax take that comes from an economy
growing well that all relies of course
on these measures working and the
economy growing Simon Clark says this
isn't a gamble but it is and a big one
thanks very much indeed Rob
you to Romford in East London now our
correspondent at shingy mararike morning
to you shingi how do people feel there
about this mini budget that's coming
later this morning what do they want to
hear from it
morning Anna so Romford where we are is
in havering which is one of the most
deprived boroughs in the capital and
it's the sort of place where the cost of
living crisis is starting to bite more
than others and today we've had you got
figures come out which are suggesting
that people are already cutting back on
their household spending because of the
cost of living going up those figures
show that among people on the lowest
incomes earning less than 20 000 pounds
a year that 28 have been forced to
reduce spending on household essentials
while 29 have had to make cuts to buying
their staple foods here it's also a
market which is starting to pick up as
you can see there are people behind me
starting to open their stools and
obviously that will be a key part of
that budget how small businesses are
supported I've had a walk around and
spoken to people who are saying that it
is already really difficult to maintain
a business one man who still sells
noodles is saying that they're the cost
of the oil the cost of the food and the
cost of getting the food there has gone
up while people who are selling clothes
even if the clothes cells are not more
expensive again the cost of putting fuel
in your van to go and pick up supply has
gone up so here we're really seeing a
crossover between the personal elements
of this cost of living crisis and also
the impact it is having on small
businesses as well I've also heard
people saying that things like ending
the National Insurance hike will help
every little helps and they are
supportive of the government statement
so what we have here is a reminder that
this will be a deeply divisive budget
with some people in support whereas
other people saying that no matter what
happens it won't be enough we're already
struggling
yeah it'd be so interesting to get
people's reaction and once we know all
the details won't it shingy thanks very
much indeed
and talking of details we will have full
coverage of the government's mini budget
in a special program on Sky News That's
from nine o'clock this morning
right now though let's take a quick look
at the front pages of this morning's
papers and let's start with the eye it's
reporting that millions of people are
facing an increase in their mortgage
payments as the UK heads into a
recession
the guardian focuses on that warning of
a recession by the bank of England as
the chancellor quasiquiteng unveils his
mini budget
in contrast the Daily Telegraph leads
with Mr quaten's warning to the bank
that it must get a grip on inflation
and biggest tax cuts for 30 years is how
the Daily Mail describes the prospects
for today's mini budget
do you say where there's lots to come in
just a moment I'm going to be joined by
The Economist and former member of the
bank of England's monetary policy
committee Andrew's sentence ahead of
that mini budget
also I'll speak to the UK's former
permanent representative to the UN Sir
Mark Lyle Grant As Leaders gathered at
the United Nations condemned Vladimir
Putin's nuclear threat
and then coming up just after eight
o'clock this morning neighbors
perspective on the mini budget I'll be
speaking to the shadow Chief secretary
to the treasury pack McFadden
now four areas of eastern Ukraine
controlled by Russia and pro-muscow
forces will begin holding referenda
today on becoming part of Russia we're
voting in the self-proclaimed republics
of luhansk and Donetsk as well as the
southern regions of Hesson and zaparisia
is expected to run until Tuesday
Ukraine's government and its Western
allies say the whole exercise is a sham
well in a moment we'll get the view from
Moscow with our correspondent there Alex
Rossi but first to our security and
defense editor Deborah Haynes is in
kharkiv for us this morning and Deborah
fill us in what's happening on the
ground and the context for these
referenda that are taking place from
today
yes this move by President Putin is an
escalation in his war effort and it
comes as a result of a lightning Advance
by Ukrainian of forces a
counter-offensive that was launched at
the end of August against Russian
positions in her son and then on the 6th
of September in this area in the
northeast of Ukraine in the kharkiv
region with Ukrainian forces retaking
swathes of territory pushing the Russian
troops right back out of largely all of
kharkiv region there is skirmishes
there's there's definite combat still
happening around certain areas including
the city of kupiansk which is at the
outer edges of the region
um but that shock Advance by Ukraine
really showing the Russian forces
wanting in terms of their ability to
hold their defensive lines
um seems to have spurred President Putin
to accelerate what had widely been
anticipated in terms of these
referendums the plan being to Annex
these territories to see them as Russian
and then that gives the Russian
president
um greater powers in terms of his
response we've obviously already had
this mobilization order but the concern
that Western allies are looking at is
the nuclear option to might a an annexed
part of Ukraine that Ukraine rightfully
tries to retake as it continues to do
then trigger Russia taking an even
Graver step in this war and escalating
it up to a nuclear conflict it's a
concern that has been alive ever since
the beginning of the large-scale
invasion back on the 24th of February
but it does seem to be growing in terms
of the concern about it no one's
panicking yet but clearly it's an option
that President Putin doesn't try to hide
when he talks about what might happen
next next
Deborah thanks very much indeed well
let's bring in Alex rossina who's in
Moscow and Alex the announcement about
referendum has come alongside a call-up
of reservists as well how has this
week's announcements these announcements
gone down amongst people there in in
Russia
well if you take into account uh Anna
the fact that only a few weeks ago
leaders in those occupied regions that
are now staging the Sham referenda was
saying that it's too early to call
referendums because all of those regions
are not fully under Russian control but
they have accelerated it there is a
sense here I think that Vladimir Putin
is somewhat rattled by the
counter-offensive that has taken place
pushing Russian forces out of the
kharkiv region and they need to now hold
these votes these sham votes as Deborah
was saying so that they can have greater
military power in terms of the assets
that they can deploy and that they have
to use it's of course similar to what we
saw in 2014 in the Crimea there a vote
on annexation was held I think something
like 95 percent of the population voted
in favor of it in inverted commas and we
can expect a similar result now it is
something of a foregone conclusion but
certainly on the ground in terms of
ordinary people here what's rattling
people a great deal is this partial
mobilization now according to the
defense Ministry that could see
something like 300 000 people drafted in
three hundred thousand men drafted in to
join the front lines into the meats
grinder in Ukraine
um but I think people are extremely
worried if you talk to ngos Human Rights
organizations they say that they have
been contacted by large numbers of
people who are extremely concerned that
their rights are going to be violated
and they will be drafted in now the
defense Ministry says that it is only
people who've had previous active
military experience but anecdotally
we're seeing that that isn't the case
either and some people say that as many
as a million people could be affected by
this now again anecdotally we are seeing
larger numbers of people trying to get
out of the country there have been
reports of large queues at the borders
of neighboring countries like Finland
young men of conscript age trying to get
out also we are seeing that the the
price of airline tickets out of Russia
two countries that you don't need a visa
to they are also increasing in price
dramatically as well so it's hard to say
at this point what effect this will have
on Russian Society but certainly
um all the signs are it could be fairly
corrosive it is something that Vladimir
Putin has so far resisted doing uh
calling people up into what is
effectively a war but he is still
calling a special military operation
Alex Rossi there in Moscow thanks very
much indeed and thanks to to Deborah
Haynes in kharkiv
making the news this morning
welcome home
five British men captured by
russian-backed forces in Ukraine are
back in the UK after an international
diplomatic effort led to a major
prisoner swap between Russia and Ukraine
Aiden Aslan seen here John Harding Dylan
Healy Andrew Hill and Sean Penner have
all been reunited with their families
after their sudden release
a 16 year old boy has been arrested on
suspicion of the murder of 15 year old
Kari McLean the teenager died in
hospital on Wednesday after being
stabbed close to the entrance of North
Huddersfield trust School in West
Yorkshire
Syrian authorities say more than 30
people have drowned after a boat
capsized off the northern Port City of
tatus the boat said to have been
carrying up to 150 refugees and migrants
is thought to have been going from
Lebanon to Europe more than a dozen
people have been rescued
Iran's president has declared that acts
of chaos are not acceptable in a warning
to protesters in the country large
numbers of people have taken to the
streets in Fury over the death of a 22
year old woman Martha amini who's been
who'd been arrested by Iran's morality
police at least nine people have been
killed in clashes since last week
as the government pushes for an electric
future on our roads drivers say there's
a lack of places to plug in in a survey
of electric vehicle owners the consumer
Group which found three-quarters of
people are unhappy with
are happy with the public charging
system about half reported difficulty
finding one that works
now a modified herpes virus has shown
promise killing off cancer cells with
one patient seeing the disease vanish
entirely patients were injected with a
drug that was a weakened form of the
cold sore virus that had been modified
to kill tumors while more research is
needed it could offer a Lifeline for
those living with Advanced stage cancer
that sounds rather amazing let's take a
look now what the weather's up to
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well today is going to bring sunshine
and showers but the South will see more
General rain for a time and it's a
mostly clear and chilly start with some
patchy fog but Southern Britain is
cloudy and Mild with outbreaks of rain
that rain will clear at Southeast Wales
through the morning but will continue to
affect Central and Southern England
Javier perhaps sundry downpours are
possible mainly near Channel coastal
areas in the Southeast elsewhere a
scattering of showers will develop from
the West
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
a Cornish Castle linked with the legends
of King Arthur is at risk of being lost
to the Sea English Heritage is warning
that tintagel could tumble into the
ocean as climate change increases the
pace of coastal erosion it's one of six
beloved spots that the Heritage body
says could be lost if nothing is done to
protect them
so just get more now on the mini budget
that we're expecting in a few hours time
well a short while ago the leveling up
secretary Simon Clark told me that the
mini budget will outline a new approach
based on growth and he denied the plan
to cut tax was a Gamble we need to get
back to the the measures that we know
work and which of course we saw during
the 1980s and 1990s helped to stimulate
a period of huge prosperity in in the
British economy and that is to say
making sure that alongside clearly a
major program of government government
investment that we focus on the real
drivers of growth and that is to say
reducing the burden of tax facing both
businesses and families that's something
which the Prime Minister put at the
heart of her leadership campaign this
summer and today we're going to see that
translated into action through what I
think will be a really important and and
game-changing financial statement you
said it was simply irresponsible for us
to whack it all on our debt when we know
that's already at a record high and you
said that just amounts to taxes being
deferred for the Next Generation so are
you now being irresponsible whacking
this all in our debt no because what
you're doing now is you're going for
growth alongside it I think the critical
thing is we need to get the economy
growing so that frankly the economic
growth trajectory outstrips that of our
debt
well that was the leveling up secretary
talking to me a little bit earlier on uh
just if in the last few minutes while we
were playing that to you we've seen the
chief secretary to the treasury Chris
phelp just arriving at Downing Street
ahead of that mini budget so it's just a
few hours away now a couple of hours
away now and uh
members of the government arriving for
the discussions before that Announcement
by quasi-quarting a little bit later on
well also in Downey Street his bdis no
doubt a call Chris felt heading into
number 10 there is a political
correspondent Rob Powell who joins me
now so we heard there from the leveling
upward secretary that this mini budget
is going to be game changing just how
radical is it likely to be do we think I
think from the tone Simon Clark adopted
we can we can see that it will be a
significant break from the previous
approach from the previous conservative
administrations we've had for the last
12 years when Chris philp the chief
secretary to the treasury just walked
into number 10 just then that's a job
that Simon Clark had before his current
role it's a job that Liz truss had
before as well he was asked by The
Waiting journalists here whether the
country can afford a tax cut and he said
absolutely that is what we will hear
today we've already had a lot of those
announcements trailed in advance around
National Insurance and corporation tax I
think that the sort of point of tension
if you like and the big unknown is is
the costings behind it and the scrutiny
that will be applied to it we know that
the obr the independent Watchdog that
essentially pulls apart the government's
figures and plots forecasts for the
coming years to tell the government how
much money they've got to spend they
won't be an obr forecast that
accompanies this mini budget today I
think given that we are likely to see
the biggest tax cutting statement in 30
years but many will see that as unusual
if not a little bit concerning in terms
of how this is all being paid for in the
short term it will be borrowing in the
long term it will be growth but it is a
gamble because there is no promise or
certainty that these measures do spur
growth so no certainty whether the
government in the long run will have the
money there from taxes to pay for it all
Rob thanks very much indeed well Rob's
raised a number of questions some of
which I will put to our next guest
because today's mini budget is being
announced after another interest rate
Rise by the bank of England which said
there'd be more to come as it fights
inflation with me now is Andrew sentence
a senior advisor to Cambridge
econometrics and a former member of the
bank of England's monetary policy
committee very good to have you here
with us this morning and so much to talk
about I'll come to the mini budget in
just a moment but first I'm very
interested in your view on yesterday's
rise in interest rates was that the
right move by the voluntary policy
committee to raise rates by 0.5 percent
well it was certainly right to raise
interest rates
um perhaps they could have gone further
because it's quite clear that the
interest rate we now have 2.25 is not
going to be sufficient to get on top of
inflation which is nearly 10
five times the bank of England's Target
so we're probably going to need further
interest rate Rises over the course of
this year and into the first part of
next year should they have done more
this time there have been an expectation
they'd go for a 0.75 rise well if I'd
been on the MPC I would been voting with
the three members who wanted a 0.75 rise
and um I think that was uh fully
Justified and we've seen in the United
States
um them raising interest rates by 0.75
on three occasions
and in Sweden for example recently they
raised interest rates by one percent so
other central banks are being a bit more
robust and a bit more
significant in terms of their interest
rate policies well yes and what do you
think the impact of the mini budget will
be as we were talking to the leveling up
secretary he was talking about a raft of
tax cuts or certainly canceling tax
Rises as part of this fiscal event what
impact will tax cuts have on inflation
well I think the danger that we face at
the moment is we've got the bank of
England pushing up interest rates trying
to keep a lid on inflation and try and
contain demand in the economy
um and then the government with the
other lever of Economic Policy fiscal
policy
um putting a big energy price support
package
um which is going to be funded by
borrowing and then we'll see later today
um quite a few tax cuts are in the
offing and that's going to add to do my
hand in the economy so it's a bit of a
push push me pull you type of situation
with economic policy with monetary
policy trying to dampen down inflation
but fiscal policy tax and government
spending policy putting more money back
into the economy so the two are working
in opposite directions the government
and the bank of England well it that's
that's the danger
um and it depends on how people respond
uh to the various measures that uh
quasi-quarting is going to announce
today I think the biggest
uh measure is going to be the energy
support package which people are talking
about being 100 to 150 billion but
there's also discussion
um or newspaper talk about uh up to 50
billion pounds of tax cuts on top of
that so that's a that's a very big
fiscal stimulus well yes and it's a lot
of money being spent but one of the
points of the energy support package is
not just to help people be able to
afford their bills of course but won't
it have an effect of dampling down
inflation by limiting prices
yes that's uh that's the sort of
um the positive side of the uh borrowing
that's going we're going to see a large
announcement of of extra borrowing uh
but the positive side is that some of
that is going towards uh helping to ease
the cost of living pressures and that
should help
um head off some of the wage pressures
which could fuel future inflation and
that's one of the dangers that we face
at the moment in the UK economy the bank
of England said yesterday that it's
possible we're already in recession do
you think they're right
well I think it's not a recession as
we've known it before I mean what
they're talking about is two
0.1 Falls in GDP in consecutive quarters
now some people would technically call
that a recession but it's it's really a
flat economy because 0.1 percent is very
close to zero
um previous recessions we've seen GDP
Falling by say one percent in a quarter
or even more
so
um I think if if you want to call this a
recession it's very mild one at the
moment
um and it's probably better
characterized as being a flat economy
well the government says that it wants
to make sure that we're not in recession
they want to boost growth with their tax
cutting plans will it work
well I think there are two impacts from
the tax cuts one is that
um if they cut taxes financed by
borrowing that puts money into people's
pockets and and they will spend it so
that's a short-term demand boost but
that brings with it the risk of
inflation we have quite a tight labor
market at the moment unemployment's very
low vacancies are very high so the risk
is that instead of in the short term
instead of fueling growth we end up with
more inflation now the the other
argument for these policies is is over
the longer term they will boost economic
growth by stimulating Enterprise and
investment
but that is a much longer term process
that may operate over five to ten years
but it certainly doesn't operate
um over one to two years well yes and
just while you're talking we're just
looking at live pictures of people
arriving for cabinets I think I saw
kitten wall towels going there into
number 10 just in the last few minutes
obviously ahead of this this big fiscal
event as the government is describing it
so how worried are you about the levels
of borrowing required for the
government's plans
well I think we have to see what the
chancellor says we know that there's
going to be a large amount of borrowing
from the energy price guarantee but as
you said that can cut both ways for the
economy it's helping ease the cost of
living pressures
but if we get an awful lot of taxing
reductions in this fiscal event when
government borrowing is already quite
strained I think that is a worry for
state of the economy and for inflation
okay well that's a a sobering note to
end on Andrew sentence thanks very much
indeed for coming in we appreciate it
and let's just go back to Downing Street
at shall we we were showing you people
arriving
um in the last few minutes of full
cabinet there's Penny mordant arriving
ahead of cabinet uh we've already seen
the chief secretary to the treasury
Chris philp arriving in the last few
minutes as well as kit Malt House as
well and Nadeem sahawi has also gone
inside too so people arriving just now
for cabinet ahead of the mini budget
which is earlier than you would normally
expect these things to be it's happening
at Hop us nine this morning
now then 20 time Grand Slam Champion
Roger Federer says he's ready for
retirement as he prepares for his final
professional match he'll be seeing off
by three of his biggest Rivals and
Friends Novak Djokovic Andy Murray and
Rafael Nadal as they team up with him
for one last time later on today at the
Laver Cup in London this guy is Jackie
beltrow went to see them on the practice
court
the end of the Federer era is a huge
blow to tennis and his millions of fans
worldwide but in true federer-esque
style he's found the perfect way to bow
out reuniting the big four against the
rest of the world on the same side of
the net as his greatest rival and friend
Rapha Nadal and in London the city of
many of his iconic moments I just felt
it would be wonderful having Borg on the
chair having the greatest players on the
planet right now alongside me and I just
felt it wouldn't feel lonely you know
because often when you retire you're
alone in the court you just probably
lost your last match and you're all
emotional talking to how much it meant
to you being in the game and I thought I
didn't want that I didn't want that sad
moment I wanted to be happy and more
like a party a party mode I was able to
to
have an amazing to create an amazing
rivalry together
um
and in the hand something that probably
we are very proud I have been a friendly
driver you know it's 20 grand
saluding the eight Wimbledon titles have
all been achieved with the style of a
ballet dancer his movement and
effortless power inspiring many players
but replicated by none of them
relatively untroubled by injury for a
quarter of a century the injured knee
that's kept him out of tennis since
Wimbledon 2021 has finally said enough
is enough I think it should be good
enough for a doubles to be honest but
for the singles uh honestly I haven't
trained at all the last three months and
it would just be too much to ask for for
the the body and I am not willing to put
all the risk on the line for that Roger
Federer and his agent Tony godsick came
up with the Laver cup to honor his Idol
Rod Laver and in a way to mimic the
Ryder Cup he long ago eclipsed his hero
in terms of titles and when he finally
says goodbye to tennis it is going to be
a special moment in sporting history
Federer has given so much to the sport
it's the end of an era and there will be
tears on and off the court
Jackie Bell trout Sky News
voting has begun in russian-controlled
parts of Ukraine in referenda that
Moscow is expected to use to justify the
annexation of four regions Ukraine's
government and its Western allies
describe the voting as a sham well here
with me to discuss that and the other
issues around Ukraine is former UK
representative to the UN Sir Mark Lyle
Grant so Mark I want to ask you about
your view on what these referenda are
all about in a moment but first let's
just focus on what happened at this
special meeting at the UN Security
Council Russia's conduct in Ukraine was
condemned widely there but how important
do you think that International
criticism is and how widespread has it
been has anyone shifted their positions
don't think we've seen a big shift in
position center to be honest it was a
big set piece event four hours of the
the U.N security Council and the vast
majority of countries that spoke
condemned the Russian invasion and their
attempts at holding the Sham referenda
over the next four days but we also saw
the fact that some of the bigger neutral
countries if you like like uh like China
like India Brazil we're still
um not naming Russia
explicitly and calling simply for a
ceasefire and dialogue and no fighting
Etc
um and we then also had Sergey lavrov
the Russian foreign minister giving a
completely Alice in Wonderland uh
account of what was going on claiming
that Mother Russia was under attack from
Neo-Nazi regime in Ukraine and that
Russia had the right to defend itself
and its uh its speakers so it was a an
important event but won't have changed I
think many Minds
well yes and ultimately how much
practical difference can condemnation at
the U.N make when Russia's got a veto on
the security Council Well it can't
that's the reality of it that the U.N is
only as strong as its members are
willing to let it be and if you are a
permanent member of the security Council
of Russia is you can always veto more
coercive action
um against you so in that sense the UN
cannot stop this conflict it can do
quite a bit you know they've been
participating in some of the prisoner
exchanges they negotiated the grain deal
for instance and they've alleviated a
lot of the humanitarian uh concerns that
crisis in Ukraine they can also gather
evidence for future Justice through
International tribunals but they cannot
directly prevent the war happening or
send in peacekeepers or anything if
Russia is prepared as it clearly is to
use its veto in the U.N security Council
but does President Putin do you think
care about the kind of criticism that
he's been under at the UN
I think he will care
um because you know even the Chinese
although they didn't name Russia uh
explicitly said that they believe very
strongly in sovereignty non-interference
territorial Integrity well that's a very
clear message to uh to Putin uh I think
and the fact that lavrov the foreign
minister turned up made his speech and
then immediately left wasn't prepared to
sit around and hear all the criticism of
Russia's Behavior you know is a sign
that that Putin can be sensitive to
criticism particularly from those who
you might expect to be more sympathetic
to him like China Brazil and India
it's not just the the referendums that
have been announced by President Putin
he's also issued nuclear threats and
he's also announced a call-up of
reservatives what's your interpretation
of what he's up to I think we're in
entering a very dangerous period now
Anna It's a combination of those two
things exactly you've got the
mobilization of at least 300 000
reservists you've got the Sham referenda
in four occupy territories now in uh
eastern Ukraine and you've got the
increasingly violent rhetoric and made
more explicit by country Medvedev uh the
number two if you like in in Russia
yesterday saying that Russia would be
prepared to use nuclear weapons to
defend its territory and I think it's
now become clear what Putin's game plan
is he will Annex these factories on the
back of the Sham referenda over the next
few days claim that they are now Russian
territory
territories are an attack on Russia
itself